too often we focus all of our attention
on our resources on developing the most
senior people in the organization if you
haven't invested some of those same
resources in developing a pipeline of
talent you may be disappointed when
people feel like they're not prepared to
assume the significant level of
responsibility
[Music]
what we're trying to do is to provide a
way for people to get that kind of
training or development a little earlier
in their careers so that they can polish
those skills and eventually grow into
their more senior leadership positions
participants will gain an understanding
of the key concepts and fundamentals
such as finance accounting operations
and abling them to make better decisions
become a better asset to the
organization that they they return
I picked a all day because I want to be
an influential leader it's more about
the behavioral aspect of being a leader
inspiring your people coping with change
markets laws are changing too quickly to
not take that time to stop and reflect
and focus on you and what you can learn
and what you can do better the break
that came after the first module is a
good opportunity to reflect on what you
were doing well and how you want to do
it how you want to move forward will
help you take what you learned here and
really implement it in your organization
it's very very practical the knowledge
is easily implementable I know I always
have resource I can tap into it the
tools the the framework even though and
then I may forget but I know how to come
back to find it the amount of takeaways
I've gotten from the other people
talking about the things we've learned
and given us just as much as the
sessions themselves the Design Thinking
the opportunity to come back the focus
on organizational behavior and your own
leadership style as well
Stanford hasn't disappointed on any of
those eld somebody said to me at a scale
of one to ten how would you rate it and
my answer was a 15 I returned to work
with so much more energy and positivity
I over clear a plan in terms of what I
wanted to implement him where I wanted
to go I am excited because I think it's
gonna make me a better leader I would
recommend this program to anyone who
wants to move the organization their own
position they're our future to the next
level
you just feel like hey I'm ready ready
to pick on any challenge without any
fear it's transformational
[Music]
you